okay you are this mission scs count
start minute 15
produce ecs for launch roger
one minute ten ten valves lock
one minute rock report range status
range green that's good to hear joshua
right there public safety there's
accounted for the fts system
uh there you see on your screen a
beautiful shot uh the skies look great
there is little wind
um happening you'd be able to see more
of the the venting um if there were wind
the trail
of that venting so uh we're ready to go
and actually that's the important point
the reason we don't see that
thing is the vent valve has been locked
up to put flight pressure into the tanks
and as we just heard they're stable at
step three which means the tanks are
ready to go
and uh here at about five seconds we
will hear the team
ecs reduce for launch 25 seconds
status check go atlas go centaur
go mars 2020. there we go we are ready
to go lift off this morning joshua
eight seven six five
five four engine ignition two
one zero related
and liftoff as the countdown to mars
continues
the perseverance of humanity launching
the next generation of robotic explorers
to the red planet
and atlas tu has gone to close loop
control
coming up on 30 seconds into flight the
rd-180 is throttling down as expected
engine response looks good
and mach 1 atlas 5 is now supersonic
and passing 45 seconds into flight
vehicle is now passing through max q
maximum dynamic pressure
and passing one minute into flight the
rd-180 is throttling back up as expected
engine response looks good at this time
in flight the srv chamber pressures
remain nominal
the rd-180 pump speed and fuel injector
pressures are responding well to demands
on the engine
standing by for srb burnout shortly and
we have burnout on all four srbs burnout
pressure signatures look good
standing by for srb jettison shortly
and we have a good indication of srb
jettison of all four srbs
and the vehicle has gone to closed-loop
guidance
vehicle body rates are responding
normally at this time
and coming up on two and a half minutes
into flight
the rd-180 is throttled down slightly as
expected engine response continues to
look good
at this time the vehicle is 50 miles in
altitude
85 miles downrange traveling at 6 000
miles per hour
and the centaur reaction control system
is now pressurizing to flight levels
and just past three minutes into flight
the rd-180 is now throttling to maintain
a constant two and a half g acceleration
limit for payload fairing jettison
engine response and vehicle acceleration
look good
and we have a good indication of payload
fairing jettison and centaur ford
forward load reactor deck jettison
and the rd-180 is throttled back is
throttling back up to attain a 4.6 g
acceleration engine response continues
to look good
and centaur has begun the boost phase
chill down sequence to thermally
condition the rl10 for operation
standing by for beco shortly
biko is the
because the call for booster engine and
we have bco booster engine cutoff
standing by for stage separation
and we have good indication of atlas
centaur separation
so there you're seeing live footage and
we have one
rl10 operating parameters look good
chamber pressures are stable
this will be the first of two burns for
today's mission
this first burn will prob be
approximately seven minutes in length
so mick that's pretty exceptional
footage there that's live video we will
see that switch over shortly
into an animation that kind of helps let
us know what's happening with the rocket
but right there
uh a beautiful liftoff fun to feel that
rumble in the building here
as we proceed towards uh orbit and then
towards
mars destination yeah absolutely it was
great watching an on time lift off of
the atlas v
with that a little over two million
pounds of thrust
cleared the tower in roughly five
seconds
josh you and i work the insight mission
and if you recall that mission on the
west coast took about 17 seconds to get
past tower
so with those four solids today this
thing really got out of here and on its
way
as we hear from jesse everything's
looking nominal and all
uh vehicle parameters are within the
design limits and
and we're getting ready to come up on a
main engine start for that first burn
that jesse was talking about
yeah so recapping this countdown to mars
stations began to be filled up this
morning just after midnight uh
preparations
fuelings powering up uh all the way
through that that liftoff that happened
uh i think it wasn't precisely on time i
think you said it was like 10
milliseconds early
um so it's pretty much dead on yeah dead
on this team does a great job as i said
they're
very focused very disciplined as torrey
also said courageous
they have done a lot of work to get us
to this point today through this
pandemic
changed how they did some of their work
you know
made adjustments as needed a lot of
cleaning a lot of things a lot of
wearing their
face masks doing all kinds of things and
so this is an exciting time not only for
the jpl team in march 2020 but
everybody that's worked this mission and
for the country in the agency so this is
exciting to see we still have a long way
to go joshua
before spacecraft separation yeah we had
a really quiet countdown today which is
phenomenal
that we got off the ground on time and
we are proceeding now that we are
in the middle of the first burn uh it's
tough to make out but that engine is lit
and it's firing um so we are in motion
there you go there's that information we
talked about
the telemetry there as we switch to a
tdrs compatible data format
tdrs overall telemetry quality is uh
very good
the space tracking system um so there
you go this is not an actual video
but this is an animation that's driven
by real data
so although we're not actually seeing
the engine on screen right now uh we can
see that the engine is lit and that is
driven by the data that says that the
engine is truly lit and we're in this
burn
yeah the launch vehicle continues to
send telemetry to the launch team via
the tdrs network
as you mentioned and that allows them to
continue to watch what's going on and
make sure all their sequence of events
meet their timeline that we continue on
a nominal flight this morning
this this first burn as we heard earlier
will be about six minutes this will get
us into that
park orbit around earth allow us to get
on our way and then get into that
approximately 30 minute coast period
that we're going to have
eight minutes into flight beginning to
see the centaur pu system balance out
mass errors um seeing very stable
body rates in the centaur
so we've mentioned five teams at play
and although if you are watching
hopefully you got a chance to see this
in person if not
on camera it's easy to kind of say oh
it's over like job done
but all five of these teams still very
much engaged still very much focused
because there's a lot of work ahead
as we proceed through this first burn
and then a coast phase like you
mentioned mick and then a second burn
and then spacecraft separation and the
acquisition of signal from
mars 2020 um so a lot more coming up
here nick i know for a launch services
program
you guys manage the launch uh so what
does that mean i mean this is this is
you guys work in action right now
by the way that's the fifth team that we
didn't get to mention we talked about
jpl we talked about doe
we talked about united space force uh
united states space force
and united launch alliance uh lsp we are
we are like the brokers uh to select
this launch
vehicle and help with manage this
mission so we we get our spacecraft
customer the jpl folks that come to us
they have some certain requirements that
they need for this mission
the launch services program made up of
engineers and
flight analysis folks and they they look
at everything they help to find those uh
requirements and then we go out and
procure a vehicle from a commercial
partner
in this case it was the atlas 541 for
the mars 2020 mission that was needed
for performance right uh as you and i
have talked over the last several days
josh one of the things that was
important for us to look at
was that performance to be able to get
mars 2020 onto that transfer orbit
into solar orbit to intercept mars and
um seven months it's kind of analogous
to a football game right
with a quarterback trying to throw a
pass downfield
you need a quarterback with a lot of
performance who can get that ball
down there where it needs to be uh and
and so the receiver
can intercept that in our case seven
months later there you go yeah it's the
longest football pass ever
uh the earth is the quarterback the
atlas is the quarterback's arm
perseverance is the football and mars is
the receiver exactly right and what we
also talked about is that
technically you could launch to mars at
any time if you had a rocket that was
powerful enough
but this is the launch period every 26
months or so as we've talked about that
makes
the most sense because you require the
least amount of energy
to get to mars because it takes a lot to
get there obviously like the atlas
541 is is a workhorse yes
torrey said it's their dominator i love
that name
for the atlas v 541 but we heard uh
jim breidenstein our national
administrator tell us that if we didn't
make this launch period we would
be down for roughly 26 months right so
the period started july 17th and
went and goes to august 15th today july
30th was one of those launch
opportunities that we had we had a
two-hour window and within that window
we had
several opportunities 25 actually 25
opportunities and we launched the
beginning of the window on our first
opportunity uh to get mars 2020 going
on its way and and that you know that
sounds like a
a lot and it is the flight analysis
group both at jpl
lsp and ula did a lot of work
to pick out those target sets and figure
out where we needed to be so they've
done a great job we'll see how this
mission continues
so tell us about the two burns required
here and we're actually coming up on the
end of the first one
ultimately a lot of people probably and
myself included at some point
just like why wouldn't you just keep
firing the engines just
fire all the way through and get to mars
in one shot
so the first burn gets us into that park
orbit